>>> JUST IN, ELON MUSK'S TWITTER
SUSPENDING THE ACCOUNT OF A
COMPETITOR, THE MOVE COMES AFTER
THE ACCOUNT SAID PEOPLE COULD
FOLLOW ELON JET, AN ACCOUNT
TRACKING MUSK'S PRIVATE PLAN ON
MASTODON BECAUSE MUSK SUSPENDED
IT ON TWITTER.
IT COMES JUST A MONTH AFTER MUSK
WROTE QUOTE MY COMMITMENT TO
FREE SPEECH EXTENDS EVEN TO NOT
BANNING THE ACCOUNT FOLLOWING MY
PLANE EVEN THOUGH THAT IS A
DIRECT PERSONAL SAFETY RISK.
NOW, THE PERSON WHO RAN ELON JET
IS A 20-YEAR-OLD COLLEGE
STUDENT.
HE IS THE ONE TRACKING MUSK'S
JET AND SAYS OTHERS SHOULD BE
WORRIED.
>> IT'S COMPLETELY UNBELIEVABLE
FROM THE FIRST MESSAGE TO HIM.
I JUST THOUGHT IT WOULD END AND
IT KEEPS GOING ON AND ON.
I THOUGHT AFTER, ESPECIALLY MY
COMMITMENT TO FREE SPEECH THAT
I'D BE FINE, BUT HE'S CHANGED
HIS VIEW.
WHOEVER THE OWNER IS, IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
THEY CAN BAN WHAT THEY DON'T
LIKE.
NOT JUST ME, THEY'RE BANNING
OTHER FLIGHT TRACKING PEOPLE.
>> "OUTFRONT" NOW, RO KHANNA,
CONGRESS IN CALIFORNIA, HE
REPRESENTS SILICON VALLEY, WHERE
AS OF NOW, IS WHERE TWITTER
STILL IS.
WE'LL SEE, RIGHT?
THIS TWITTER ACCOUNT TRACKING
THE JET, THIS IS ONE ACCOUNT.
I WANT TO START BIGGER THAN THAT
ONE ACCOUNT.
FIRST, THE BIGGER PICTURE.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
THIS MEANS OR WHAT TWITTER UNDER
ELON MUSK WILL LIKE LIKE?
HE'S THE GOD OF TWITTER.
HE CAN DECIDE WHO GETS TO SPEAK
AND WHO DOESN'T.
>> HE GETS TO MAKE THE RULES AND
IT DOESN'T SEEM CONSISTENT.
I'VE BEEN DEFENDING THE IDEA OF
FREE SPEECH AND THAT WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE CENSORED THE "NEW
YORK POST," BUT YOU CAN'T THEN
SENSOR SOMEONE WHO'S TRACKING
PRIVATE FLIGHTS.
SO I HOPE THEY'LL RECONSIDER IT,
BUT THE BIGGER ISSUE IS THERE
HAS TO BE SOME INDEPENDENT BODY.
THEY CAN BE THE BE JUST ELON
MUSK MAKING THE DECISIONS OF
WHICH ACCOUNT TO SUSPEND AND
WHICH TO HAVE ON.
>> THAT'S THE THING.
THEY'VE COME OUT WITH ALL THESE
REVELATIONS, THEY SAY, WHO IS
DECIDING WHAT AT TWITTER.
MAYBE THERE WERE SOME MISTAKES,
BUT AT LEAST THERE WAS A SYSTEM
YOU COULD GO THROUGH AND LOOK AT
IT IN RETROSPECT AS OPPOSED TO
JUST ONE PERSON'S BRAIN.
ON THE ELON JET, THE LAST TWEET
BEFORE THAT ACCOUNT WAS
SUSPENDED SHOWED MUSK'S JET
TAKING OFF FROM OAKLAND MONDAY,
LANDING IN LOS ANGELES 48 MINLS
LATER.
ANOTHER DAY, HE FLAGS A JET
TAKING OFF FROM RENO TO OAKLAND.
VERY DETAILED.
EVERYWHERE HE GOES WAS ON
TWITTER.
HE RAN ACCOUNTS LIKE BEZOS JET.
CELEB JETS.
OTHER CELEBRITIES, WHERE THEY
WERE GOING.
SWEENEY SAYS THIS IS ALL
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
BUT PUBLICLY AVAILABLE IS
DIFFERENT THAN EASILY
ACCESSIBLE.
SO DOES IT CROSS THE LINE OR
DOES ELON HAVE A POINT THAT
PUTTING HIS PRIVATE JET AND
EVERYWHERE IT GOES THAT HE'S
CHANGED HIS MIND AND SAYS IT'S A
THREAT?
>> THEY PUT OUT MY PERSONAL
E-MAIL.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
THEY DID NOT.
>> BUT I THINK THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BELIEVE IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT PRINCIPLE, YOU'VE GOT
TO BE CONSISTENT AND HAVING
PUBLIC INFORMATION OUT THERE, AS
LONG AS IT'S NOT AN IMMINENT
THREAT TO SAFETY, SHOULD BE ON
THERE.
NOW, IF HE IS SAYING GO TAKE
SOME ACTION AGAINST ELON MUSK OR
SOMEONE, THAT'S DIFFERENT.
THAT'S A THREAT TO SAFETY.
AND I WOULD AGREE THAT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE ON THERE.
I JUST LOOKED BEFORE COMING ON
THE SHOW.
AARON RUPER HAS BEEN BANNED.
HE CRITICIZES ME ALL THE TIME.
YOU CAN'T BAN THAT.
SO I THINK WHAT THIS WHOLE
TWITTER IS SHOWING IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THOUGHTFUL DECISION
MAKING AND WE HAVE CONCENTRATION
OF POWER IN WHO'S DECIDING WHAT
IS SPEECH.
>> AND ALSO I THINK ONE THING
THAT'S SHOWING IS THERE ARE NO
EASY ANSWERS.
IT'S EASY TO SAY I DON'T LIKE
HOW IT'S DONE.
IT'S DIFFERENT TO DO IT
YOURSELF.
ONE THING MUSK HAS BEEN DOING IS
TWEETING THINGS, THEY ARE THINGS
RECOGNIZED BY THE QANON
COMMUNITY.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHY HE'S DOING IT,
BUT THE WHITE RABBIT, HE TWEETED
FOLLOW THEN THE LITTLE PICTURE
OF A WHITE RABBIT.
NOW I ADMIT, I FIRST SAW THAT
AND WAS THINKING WHAT THE HECK
IS THIS.
THE WHITE RABBIT HAS BEEN LINKED
TO THE MOVEMENT OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS AND FORUMS
IMMEDIATELY PICKED THIS UP.
HE'S DISMISSED THESE ALLEGATIONS
AN SAID IT WAS ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE, BUT A JOURNALIST WHO WAS
AN EXPERT ON QANON, HE SAYS
FOLLOWERS SAW THIS AS TIPPING
THE HAT.
ELON GETS US.
HE'S WITH US.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT STUFF
LIKE THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW HE'S DOING THAT.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY HAS
INNOVATED WITH TESLA.
HE'S INNOVATED WITH SPACEX.
WHY HE'S GETTING IN BACK AND
FORTHS ON QANON AND SUSPENDING
ACCOUNTS ON TWITTER, IT SEEMS A
TOTAL WASTE OF TIME.
HE SHOULD NOT BE MAKING THE
DECISIONS ON THIS AND IT'S
CONCERNING.
IT'S CONCERNING THAT HE'S
PUTTING THIS STUFF OUT THERE.
THE TWEET AND FAUCI AND
PROSECUTING FAUCI.
IT'S ONE THING TO SAY --
>> PRONOUNS PROSECUTE FAUCI.
>> WHEN YOU ARE ONE OF T